[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michael podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him is the clown car out of
clowns is that is that what is
happening like they're waiting for the
clown speaker to emerge from the clown
car but the clown car is out of [__]
clowns is that
what
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan do
it do it just do it already would you
just just do it already what are you
waiting for why are you standing around
waiting to make him speaker yeah that's
right I said it that's what we should do
is let them choose the biggest clown of
them all and step on that [__]
rake good morning it's Monday October
16th
a lot of you joined last night for
karaoke night I appreciate if you guys
joined over on Twitch for karaoke we had
a lot of fun last night I kind of ran
out of jger like literally ran out of
Jagger yeah I did some shots uh on WE
sang some songs we listen to some songs
we hung out for a while we talked on air
and
and and we discovered that we like
hanging out drinking and singing karaoke
on Twitch so it it's a fun time I really
appreciate H all those who joined in
last night we were doing it for three
and a half hours three and a half hours
we were hanging out singing songs and
that sort of thing talking yapping back
and forth we didn't talk a lot of
politics a little bit that's right three
and a half hours and we weren't talking
that much politics can you believe that
it is a thing that happened so I want to
thank everyone who came last night who
put in song requests um who who bought
who bought shots gave tip jar U thank
thank you for coming thank you for
supporting if you guys want to join in
on this in the future just go to the
Tony michaels.com that's right you go to
the Tony michaels.com let me show you
how to get there and you know I'll show
you how that works we'll go let's see
here we'll go to the Tony michaels.com
here it is and you can actually uh if
you go to the Tony michaels.com all the
karaoke stuff is still at the top for
karaoke night for last night you can
watch it on Twitch you can still give in
the tip jar there and you can go follow
on patreon now patreon members had a
chance to get up on screen a few people
got up on screen and talk to me ask a
few questions we chatted a little bit
and then they went back down into the
comments and twitch so thank you for
joining us last night George and
pazzi um but here's the thing if you
want to follow patreon you can follow
for free now you won't get to see
everything on patreon but you get to
follow me over there which is going to
be very important so if you want to
subscribe to the Tony michaels.com and
go follow me on patreon I'm going to
communicate a lot of stuff over there
more and more as we go also do not
forget to join the Discord as well we're
building a huge community over there
there's over 600 people over there now
uh on on the Discord which is crazy
right here let me put the link in the uh
in the chat here so you guys have it
that way you guys can go join the
Discord when you go into the Discord you
got to verify all you got to do is press
the the green check mark and if you're
confused just go to the Welcome Center
once you get in the Discord there just
go to the Welcome Center it has
directions there on how to get verified
so don't forget to do that when you
enter the Discord and you enter the
conversation over there with the [__]
them fam boom
shakalaka I am so excited that it is
Monday October 16th and Republicans
still can't figure out their [__]
I'm excited about it I know a lot of
people are really upset they're like oh
my god oh what what we could do W oh man
so bad what did you think was going to
happen what the [__] did you think was
going to happen if you elect children to
do an adult's job Mya children and mind
you these [__] people are clowns you
didn't know this you didn't know that
Trump is the authoritarian dictator of
the Republican party and you put them in
charge of the House of Representatives
the [__] is wrong with you and you
expect it not to be complete utter chaos
Trump is their leader hello hello um I'm
sorry someone David said Here on YouTube
that's insult insulting the kids it is
that is kind of insulting children if
you want to know the honest truth
children are much more well- behaved
than the [__] manga Republicans in
the house now the story is this morning
that Jim Jordan is gonna be the speaker
if he had enough votes see that's the
thing about uh elections you got to have
enough votes to win that would be great
there was another guy from Georgia what
the [__] his name hey can you can you
look up the irrelevant republican from
Georgia who thinks he's going to be the
speaker of the house even though he
doesn't want to be the speaker of the
house he's an next he wants to Paul Ryan
himself can he can his [__] bonehead
I think his name's Scott or something
he's from Republic or from Georgia he's
a republican from Georgia what the [__]
who gives a [__] about this guy why does
this guy want to Paul Ryan
himself you know that's why none of them
want to be speaker anyways right none of
them want to be even Jim Jordan Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan when it
came like he was like whoa this could be
a reality I really could be the speaker
of the house they put a microphone in
front of his face weeks ago right after
Kevin McCarthy was vacated they were
like are you gonna run for speaker of
the house and he's like uh I don't
really want to because it'll expose me
of all my flaws which are a lot did you
know Jim Jordan doesn't even know what a
bill is I mean I'm only assuming that
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
doesn't know what a bill is just like he
doesn't know how to protect his students
from uh being sexually molested in the
shower kind of kind of funny isn't it
that Jim Jordan doesn't know what a bill
is you know how I know Jim Jordan Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan doesn't
know what a bill is he's never he's
never been he's never wrote one he's
never he's never sponsored one he's
never brought one to a committee because
he's not Republicans don't do these
things they don't do these things called
um what's that called legislating yeah
they don't do that kind of stuff they
just go be Congress people to be famous
on social media and Fox News you see see
that that's their stick and they were
really good at that when Democrats would
win
elections and and this is the dog that
caught the car type thing you know what
I mean they caught the car and now [__]
they don't know what to do I have no
idea oh we're supposed to be able to
govern well [__] that sucks because we
definitely don't know how nor do we want
to govern [__] out of here and we're
surprised by these things the media's
surprised these commentators these
leftwing commentators are surprised out
there yeah that's right I'm gonna tack
them too hang on just [__] don't put
your seat Bel on we're gonna get to it
that's right I'm gonna attack the left
just like I [__] said the other day
that them saying that Trump says Obama
when he's talking about Biden is him G
Dom that is not what that is and you
lying about it actually play plays to
Trump's hand here he's speaking of
foreign language he's speaking qanon to
these people okay that's what he's doing
when he calls Biden Obama he's not out
of his mind he's not I mean he has lost
his marbles but again as I said before
he didn't actually lose his marbles his
marbles pack their [__] and left oh they
were so pissed off can you imagine being
the marbles in Donald Trump's head
oh [__] I'd have been pissed off too I'd
have been like come on Susie get your
[__] pack your suitcase we're getting
the [__] out of here this guy's [__]
nuts get your [__] we're out of here he
didn't lose his marble they [__]
left but that doesn't mean that he has
some sort of Dementia or him calling
Biden Obama is dementia it is him
speaking qanon which is way more
dangerous than him being out of his mind
if you want to know the God's honest
truth it's way more dangerous for him to
be speaking qinon to these people
people you understand that right lefties
who are who are who are lying you're
lying you're lying you're you're full of
[__] he doesn't have dementia because
he's saying Obama is Biden that's not
what he's saying he's speaking q and on
and that is that is the real [__]
thing that we need to be paying
attention to okay you don't want to
underestimate these [__] fascist all
right you do not want want to
underestimate these fascist don't
underestimate them what you need to do
is put them on the defense you know what
really put them on defense when they
elect a speaker and the entire country
goes you're gonna do
what put them on the
defense let them let them be on the
defense one of the ways to do that is
let them do what they want because they
love stepping on reiks as Derek said in
the pre-show today let's throw out bear
you know they throw out rates for
themselves to step on let's throw out
bear traps for them let's do that [__]
yeah let's throw out some big ass bear
traps and the biggest bear trap we can
throw out for him is to piss the
American people off when they when they
pick Jim Jordan Jim I don't report sex
crimes
Jordan as their leader in the house he
ain't gonna get [__] done [__] he
couldn't Jim Jordan had had control of
the weaponization committee and he could
even convince the country that Hunter
Biden stole money he couldn't even
convince them of that he couldn't
convince them he couldn't even convince
Barry Weiss the prosecutor that was
assigned to prosecute and indict Hunter
Biden that he'd stole money the only
thing he could convince Barry weit of
David Weiss excuse me not Barry weit
David Weiss the prosecutor in Delaware
is that Hunter Biden bought some guns
that's it that's it that's it
Jim Jordan is a [__] idiot he's a
clown good put him in charge good luck
to you good luck to you let them step on
this rake why are why are we taking the
shovel out of their hands when they're
trying to dig their political grave stop
doing that stop
it if they want to throw rakes to jump
on let them do it like Dereck said throw
bear traps out for him yeah let's
[__] do that nail those bear traps to
the ground and let them step in them but
when they're digging their political
grave you don't take the shovel out of
your hands you go get him a backo you go
get him a d8 matter of fact yeah let's
[__] dig that grave and let's [__]
bury you forever let's do
that it's enough of this [__] that that
we got to stand back and let them
destroy our country and and and we're
going to try to help them hide it what
are you talking why are we helping them
hide hide how they want to destroy our
country how are we why are we trying to
run cover for them the [__] are you
talking about they can't even pick a
speaker there's 20 people okay there's
20 people that don't want to vote for
Jim Jordan Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan the main reason why the main
reason
why is because those 20 will lose their
[__] seats if Jim Jordan is elected
speaker so [__] them so [__] them [__]
them [__] them [__] them today tomorrow
next week next month next [__] year
[__] them let them pick them let them
lose those [__] races because frankly
every single moment that they stand back
and let anyone in the house consider Jim
I don't report sex crimes Jordan as
their Speaker of the House only makes us
one step closer to Democrats winning the
house and AEM Jeff being a functional
speaker who can actually actually I
don't know do the work of the people
that they [__] elected them to do so
what do you want do you want to stand
back and [__] argue over which
Speaker of the House Donald Trump is
gonna control because that is the
[__] matter of the fact here is that
Donald Trump controlled Kevin McCarthy
Donald Trump will control Jim Jordan
Donald Trump will control whoever is the
Speaker of the House whoever it is it
does not matter they are controlled Lock
Stock Barrel by Donald
Trump and if you don't know that you
have not been paying a [__] attention
and I want to tell the media thanks for
finally paying attention to Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan I've been
calling Jim Jordan Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan for many years now and
you notice that the media has never
caught on to that but finally finally
finally even after he was the chairman
of the Judiciary Committee the [__]
media didn't have enough balls to ask
Republicans why in the [__] does a guy
who look the other way when his student
athletes were being [__] molested in
a shower by his coaching staff why the
[__] did you make him the chairman of
the goddamn Judiciary Committee and the
weaponization committee didn't have the
[__] balls on them to ask those
questions forget about Republicans
answering it because you're not going to
get a [__] decent answer from any
Republican anywhere of why they think
Jim Jordan's a good leader because he's
a goddamn [__] sex crime Hider not
only that he's a goddamn insurrectionist
that some [__] tried to overthrow our
government you kidding me he's one of
the architects in the house of the coup
attempt [__] you and and the media's oh
man they were on top of it weren't they
they were like oh how do you feel about
Jim Jordan looking the other way when
the six crimes in Ohio State and then
they put the microphone Republicans
Republicans just [__] crickets
[__]
crickets and because they're like well I
don't really care that he looked the
other way for sex crimes because I
really I really don't care that
Republicans don't give a [__] of sex
crimes being committed I mean as long as
long as they're Republicans committing
sex crimes they're okay with that oh
[__] they're okay with that stupid
[__] movie they put out that qinon
movie with the the [__] Jesus freak
you know what I'm talking about what's
his name the guy that played Jesus in
the in the Mel Gibson movie that [__]
idiot yeah that that they don't care
about that [__] they don't care about
the [__] churches and the pastors all
over the
country that are [__] getting caught
up in pedophilia and sex crimes they
don't want to talk about
that they definitely don't want to talk
about Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan neither did the media until this
last week or two cavel that's right that
[__] cavel doesn't that sound like a
even his name sounds like a dig like I
don't have to make up some [__] weird
nickname for Jesus Jesus cavel the cavel
Jesus you know what I mean that name
just oh my
God I don't what to tell you I mean I
love to sit here and tell that oh my God
we got to go on the offense we have to
make
sure we have to make
sure let let we let we defend the house
and let we make sure that Jim Jordan
isn't the speaker of the house and all
that [__] what the [__] are you talking
about why do we have to sit here and
[__] fix their problem why why do is
it up to us to fix their
problem
why why are we standing around having
discussion why it's our problem it's not
our problem it's a they problem it's a
them problem so so dump Donald Trump hey
there's a hey y hey hey maanga you want
a solution you want a solution that you
can pick a house Speaker dump Trump tell
him to [__] off tell him to go pound
[__] sand stop being scared of that
[__] that's what you can do
because you know what if you told Donald
Trump to [__] off you can nominate
someone else as your Republican
Presidential nominee you could
definitely get a speaker of the
house you could definitely get a speaker
of the house if you dump Trump but
you're not going to you're not going to
because you love the Trump drug you
[__] love it you love that he gives
you permission to be the worst versions
of yourself so why would you want to get
rid of him why would you want to get rid
of your of the [__] problem when it's
the thing it's theug drug you love the
most the hate oh you [__] love the
hate just snorted up your
nostril oh man I love my cocaine laced
with hate [__] out of here they're not
going to do that so let them do it let
them step on that
rake stop trying to convince the entire
country that somehow they're not going
to pick Jim Jordan or someone like him
or some scumbag that is equally scummy
is that piece of [__] from Ohio come on
now this is Republicans we're talking
about here who do you think's going to
emerge from the Republican party to be a
great speaker you think someone for the
Republican party is gonna Ascend and be
the greatest speaker in the history of
ever get the [__] out of here you're
gonna be standing around waiting a long
goddamn time for that kind of [__] and I
know the delusion on the left is that
Republicans are GNA vote for for hem
Jeff but you are outside your [__]
mind that's right you are outside your
[__] mind and you don't know how MAA
politics works if you think if you think
a republican is g to vote for a Keem
Jeff oh man that's almost like hoping
that secretaries of state are gonna 14th
Trump
unilaterally you're gonna stand around a
long time waiting for that stupid ass
[__] that's right why does the left
continue to fight battles that they know
they're going to lose why do we do that
why do we spend time developing
narratives that are just all [__]
you know what I mean it's kind of
[__] stupid ain't it why why are we
standing around trying to create a
narrative that MAA shouldn't pick Jim
Jordan and frankly I'm telling you right
here and right now there's no one better
to represent those [__] vile fascist
scumbags than Jim
Jordan he really is the picture perfect
leader for those [__] disgusting
pieces of
trash they [__] make a mockery of our
government they make a mockery of our
goddamn democracy just like Jim Jordan
does he's the picture perfect [__]
speaker for them sons of [__] isn't
he really when you think about it come
on he represents them really to to a
tea and really honestly they should they
deserve a piece of [__] like Jim Jordan
as their leader they really do they
deserve deserve that [__] they've earned
it as a matter of
fact they've earned that scumbag Jim
Jordan why am I a masochist well the
reason I'm not a masochist I'm just
saying why are we preventing them from
being that why are we trying to stop
them from destroying themselves why why
they're fascist they're [__]
Nazis can you imagine if you could
rewind to 1930 and watch the Nazis
destroy themselves and not be able to
take
power imagine just imagine the history
that would lay before us if that was
possible they should have done it they
should have done it if it was
possible don't take the shovel out of
their hands when they're digging their
political grave it's the same thing with
the RFK Jr [__] we we've been over this
I laughed at at at people surmising that
RFK Jr was gonna somehow somehow how
nominate or or mount a campaign for the
nomination of the democratic party I
laughed at it because it's absolutely
[__]
ridiculous and the right-wing wanted it
so bad so much so that they convinced
their entire base that RFK Jr was
[__] awesome he lifts weights he's
got muscles he's got muscles he's a real
man I'm a real boy now we got RFK Jr he
he hates
vaccines and he's a [__] lunatic so
we love
him okay great how is that gonna work
out for you keep
going why would I stand in there
hey it's really stupid
stuff oh you thought I was going to come
here and talk about Israel and
Hamas well manga manga is is America's
Hamas um and we should we should
definitely definitely not stand in the
way when they're trying to destroy
themselves speaking of Hamas I want to
tell you a narrative I want to tell you
a narrative that the rightwing is going
to try to spend over the next few days
that Joe Biden Joe Biden
Joe Biden wrote a check to Hamas to
attack Israel that's what they're going
to say you know they tried the six
billion doll thing you remember that
they're like J bid J bid gave Iran $6
billion do you remember that [__] and
even Fox News is like yeah that's that
um we we were saying that originally but
now we know that's all [__] like
they just totally [__] totally
[__] destroy that narrative right
because it was all a lie
so this morning they're like
humanitarian Aid that the American
government has been giving Palestinians
into Gaza City for years is somehow Joe
Biden Jo bad in attacking
Israel okay so let me tell you something
this is the stupid um thing that manga
does right because they know they're
losing the War uh of the narrative
uh in in the conflict in Israel okay
they're losing that narrative and the
reason why they're losing that narrative
is because the president United States
Joe Biden came out immediately
immediately and supported the Israeli
government because they were [__]
brutally
attacked by a fascist terrorist
organization called
Hamas they were attacked okay now right
now right now as right now as we speak
there is tons
of Aid of humanitarian Aid sitting on
the other side of the Egyptian border
okay and the Egyptians has
agreed they haven't followed through
with their agreement yet but the
Egyptians have agreed that they will let
Americans Palestinian Americans who are
in Gaza cross over the Egyptian
border and they will let that
humanitarian Aid to give to the
Palestinians you know like I don't know
food water you know the the [__] that
everyone's been saying oh they shut out
your oh oh
you're you've been shutting out your
food what there's water waiting for
Palestinians on the other side of the
Egyptian border that the
Americans are going to give to them
water food humanitarian Aid okay
supplies for I don't know um hospitals
that sort of [__] I don't know well
maybe maybe maybe maybe just maybe maybe
just maybe the Biden Administration are
are
Humane maybe that a
thing and maybe we should stop [__]
going to X formerly known as [__]
elon's Twitter and stop [__]
believing every stupid ass thing that
you see I don't give a [__] what the
[__] narrative
is the truth is is that a a a terrorist
organization who is elected to be the
government of Gaza in 2007
folks well six actually but almost 20
years Hamas has had control over Gaza
and only one election only one [__]
election there a fascist terrorist
organization and for anyone I don't give
a [__] who you are anyone to stand in
support of
Hamas especially especially people who
consider themselves part of the lgbtq
community or Allies of the lgbtq
community which I consider myself one I
would I would [__] go down fighting
defending rights of some other person I
don't care what their
Creed let me tell you something about
Hamas you're the first one they cut your
[__] head off and burn you alive
first
[__] they saw you with your
pride frag align your [__] I don't it
wouldn't give a [__] if you had a
Palestinian flag and a pride flag they
cut your [__] head off and they burn
you alive because they're fascist
murderous [__]
terrorist okay that's Hamas you got it
Hamas is an ideology Hamas is a [__]
political party they won an election in
Gaza almost 20 years ago and never
allowed another election do you
understand who the [__] Hamas is what
what Hamas has done to Gaza is what Maga
wants to do to our
country pluck your [__] head out of
your ass you got it it's much more
nuanced than oh well if you're for
Israelis not being attacked by a
murderous [__] fascist terrorist
organization and somehow you're anti-
Palestinian [__] you you could be human
you could be human on both sides because
here's what I say free Palestine from
[__]
Hamas that's what I say free Palestine
from [__]
Hamas those [__] pieces of
trash you think you think that [__]
Hamas is any better than these [__]
fascist here
they want to eradicate use legislation
to get rid of our [__] countrymen
[__] out of here with this [__] and if
you're an ally and you're and you're
acting as if [__] Hamas is oppressed
[__]
you [__]
you again me being an ally I'd be one of
the first ones that they cut my [__]
head off and Burn Me Alive because I
would I would go down burning in [__]
flames to tell Hamas that they can take
their [__] ancient goddamn beliefs
and stick them straight up their
religious zealous
asses that's right [__] them there is
more goddamn Humanity than
that and I mean we can go back and we
can argue the history of the land and
all that
[__] well let me tell you something
the Israeli government gave those
Palestinians warning that they are going
to come into Gaza City guess what Hamas
did not tell Israel when they went and
[__] murdered thousands of innocent
civilians in Israel not combatants not
[__] troops not not not military on
the [__] border civilians they went
and they [__] murdered
civilians an
atrocity an act of
War
war crimes to be
exact guess how many pamphlets Hamas put
into Israel about that not a [__]
one so I get it I get it you don't like
Benjamin Netanyahu I'm not a [__] fan
either [__] BB as far as I'm concerned
[__] that guy that corrupt [__]
he's a goddamn fascist
too but it doesn't get rid of the fact
it doesn't get rid of the fact
just because that is true doesn't mean
other [__] ain't true
either stop acting like it's not truth
stop just because it's not convenient
for you just because it's not convenient
for your
message it is the absolute right of
Rasheed Talib to have a Palestinian flag
and a pride flag in front of her
Congressional office it's [__] dumb
as dog [__] I'll say that that's the
dumb as [__] thing that you can
[__]
do it's the absolute right for people to
protest in New York or wherever with the
Palestinian flag and a [__] pride
flag right next to each other it's dumb
as dog [__] it's dumb as dog
[__] but it's the right here in this
country guess what guess what wouldn't
be the right to have a Palestinian flag
and a pride flag guess where it wouldn't
you wouldn't have the right to do it
guess where you would be [__]
murdered if you held a Palestinian flag
and a pride flag in both hands guess
where guess where [__] guess
where Gaza they [__] murder you you
in last two seconds holding up a pride
flag and a Palestinian flag you wi last
two [__]
seconds get it through your thick
goddamn
skulls religious is sick religions are
[__]
sick where do you think all war comes
from where do you think all killing
comes from the humanity religion doesn't
exist if we don't keep our Humanity you
know that right how do we expect
religious religion to be humanitarian if
we can't keep our [__]
Humanity half the goddamn people in Gaza
City listen to me when I tell you this
half the people in Gaza City weren't
even alive during the last election in
Gaza the last
election they weren't even [__]
alive do Palestinian people deserve to
get [__] murdered because they're
from Gaza City [__] no do Israelis
[__] deserve to get murdered because
they're from Israel are they're of a
religion [__] no
no just like I'll Stand and be an ally
to anyone in this country I'll support
listen I will I will stand on the on the
[__] foundation of the right for
Nazis to go to an overpass in Florida
and
protest as long as their L their hate
doesn't leak out into crimes I will
defend their right I will defend their
right to have that stupid ass ass vile
opinion and to say it out
loud we got to have some godamn
humanity and the right is going to try
to take advantage of their
inhumanity they're inhumane the right
Maga in this country is America's Hamas
they're America zamas and they're going
to take advantage of that they're going
to pump this [__] deep-seated hate
hate [__]
filled wankery into these [__] idiots
brains Joe bid Joe Biden gave
humanitarian Aid to Gaza yeah so did
Trump so did Obama so did [__] Bush
you dumb sons of
[__] how do you think humanitarian
Aid
Works how do you think it
works get it
straight it's time we [__] have some
strategic outrage about this it's time
that we beat back on not just one set of
messaging but another set of
messaging and I said it from the very
beginning when I came on the air last
Monday after the terrible [__]
terrorist attack that killed over a
thousand
Israelis the needless [__] hatred
the
inhumanity that those [__] fascist
terrorists went into Israel and murdered
civilians a war crime I said it was
Humanity that we need to stand on and I
stand by that today don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$2999 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast some people like when I when I
get loud scream a few of
you I'm not screaming at you I'm
screaming with you I
promise I promise which is kind of funny
I don't know if you guys have been um
checking out the YouTube shorts that
we've been posting we're going to start
posting those are over social media by
the way
that's right we're going to start
[__] carpet bombing social media with
Tony Michaels that's going to
happen I've already got plans
to put this all over social media and
the reason why is um when we started
doing these shorts right I'm yelling I'm
[__] yelling and raging because you
guys as the audience I don't don't tell
these [__] maglites this we should
keep this a secret right because you
guys are kind of in on this thing right
so like when I'm yelling and screaming
at manga like you guys know I'm talking
to them not you right like you get it
you [__] get it you guys are in on it
the best part is like when we cut it as
a short on YouTube they have no [__]
clue they don't know what's going on
they don't know like I pop up they've
never seen me before like oh this is a
white guy with a beard and a backwards
hat he should definitely love Trump and
they're feeding it to me and my
algorithm so I'll definitely love this
guy and then I say what I say and soon
after that like you you're your your
beard sucks your hats t terrible oh you
must be from California you must bu be
one of them libtards you know what I
mean it's hilarious and the best part is
like here's the thing is YouTube YouTube
fees it to the audience first like the
followers right like okay we'll show it
to you know the algorithm's like we'll
show it to some of Tony's followers and
it gets like 1,200 views and then it
sits there for like three days like
laying in weit you know what I mean just
like just waiting there just waiting for
manga you know what I mean and and like
they'll give it like two views here 10
views here 20 views there and then all
of a sudden they're like all right feed
it toaga hurry up and it's like bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang and it
just pisses them off so much because
literally when they pop up the clip I'm
yelling at
them like literally I'm yelling at them
the person holding the phone oh they
[__] they they [__] hate it and a
lot of times
you'll get the manga they're so [__]
pissed off that I'm yelling at them and
I might be yelling Truth at them you
know what I
mean but they they go to the channel and
they watch other [__] shorts and they
comment on other shorts that's how
pissed off they
are I love it I love it listen a lot of
lefties will not Embrace uh their
content getting inside the Maga universe
and the reason why he CU like oh I don't
want that because in up bearing all the
trolls it'll bring all the hate they'll
leave all kinds of hateful comments [__]
them let them let them
comment go ahead I don't give a [__]
comment all day long you [__] [__]
eater that just feeds it to more people
like you that's all it does because they
don't understand that you know they're
dumb as dog [__] so they don't
understand like they see a video that
they don't like so in instead of instead
of like just scrolling past it they rage
watching like four times like oh I'm
definitely going to comment on this
[__] so then they then they go
in the comment section they comment like
three times because they they do one
comment that one ain't good enough so
then they do another comment and then
they see other [__] MAA rage wanking
in the [__] comments so they comment
underneath them they're like yeah Trump
2024 and [__] like that you know what I
mean and it just makes it to where the
algorithm's like hey you know what's
weird this video really this video
really gets these [__] going
they really engage they comment like a
sun [__] and not only that they watch
it like three and four times in a row
then they go to Tony's page and they
watch more of his shorts and comment on
more of them they must really like these
things that's why so so like when you
see my my shorts and they've got like
four or five thousand views [__]
3,000 views are
[Music]
maglites oh my God it's so funny it's so
funny I love it so
much oh love it so much this is what I'm
here for I'm here you know and that's
why I got so good at yelling and
screaming at MAA on this show because
I'm not screaming at you I'm screaming
at them I'm screaming with you at them
if that makes sense and I know you guys
are in on it like that you're like yeah
that's we love Tony's you know righteous
anger or his strategic outrage or his
cathartic [__] release like that's
you say the [__] I want to say to them
and you know what I am actually saying
it to them now like literally YouTube is
making sure that my me yelling at them
gets fed to them so just know that
they're going to keep getting a healthy
diet of Tony yelling and screaming at
them oh my God I think a lot of them are
followers now on YouTube like they're F
me just so they can just so they can go
rage wnk to the Tony Michaels shorts
they found they found a way to rage wink
all day long if they want
to oh [__] him [__] him [__] him I want
to tell you I had I had a great time
last night again on karaoke and for
those who couldn't join last night or
don't know what karaoke is I actually
sang karaoke last night if you want to
go rewatch it you can go to the twitch
Channel make sure if you go to the
twitch channel that you tell everyone Hi
but also subscribe there and follow
there that's important if you follow
it's free if you subscribe you can
actually use your Amazon Prime account
to make it free uh and then I get a
little bit of money from Amazon for you
to do that doesn't cost you anything if
you're Prime user but you can do that uh
someone says what's this karaoke over on
Twitch that's the thing we did we did
karaoke on Twitch last night a lot of
people uh actually left tips in the
request yard we had a few few requests
we had one for Whiskey Bent Hellbound um
Hank Williams and Junior we had a bad
Brad Paisley request I seen country
music so if you don't like country music
well [__] off but if you like country
music or you want to hear me sing you
can go rewatch it on Twitch it's over
there for a little bit um the the the
replay of it so go go you can go to the
Tony michaels.com click the watch Twitch
it'll take you over there if you wanna
if you want to give support for karaoke
you can throw in the tip jar but there
was also some people from patreon that
came on the screen with me so if you
want to follow me on patreon it's it's
free now to follow me on patreon you're
not going to see everything if you
follow me you're going to see some of
the public posts that I post on patreon
but you won't see the the paid post um
but you can go follow me on patreon and
you should because it's a community that
we're trying to build uh you should also
go to the Discord and get in on the
Discord it's where the chat party never
stops over there in Discord they're
they're chatting right now there's a
live chat room excuse me there's a live
show chat room is what I meant to say
over there on uh on Discord so a lot of
people gather up and they're chatting
there during the live show um some wild
stuff goes on in the Discord so if
you're a pearl clutcher you probably
wouldn't like it but most of you people
in the are not Pearl clutchers in the
first place so yeah they'll welcome you
over there on the Discord here I'll put
the I'll put the link in the in the chat
for you here you go here's the link
here's the link for the Discord there it
is go over and and join the Discord when
you go into the Discord you got to
verify that you're a human we want to
know that you're you're a human a human
that you got Humanity over there on the
discords we want to see your Humanity
over on the Discord so make sure you go
to the Welcome Center and verify as you
go into the Discord okay so let's get to
some clips here let me see if let's pull
this one down let's pull the other one
up let's go to let's go to the Tweety
tweets and one of these days I'm I'm GNA
make sure that we don't have to have
Twitter to do this type of [__] but uh
we're just we're just in this stupid
[__] hole until we do all right so
the
so um MAA really can't figure out how to
select a speaker right U but it's not
surprising they know how to select a
speaker let me show you why this is
[__] wild [__] I show you this [__]
all the time you know what I mean at
these these MAA rallies this is in
Michigan and this is why they can't
select the speaker okay I I I know it
sounds like what Tony you're gonna show
us a clip of some dumbass Maga supporter
in Michigan in a line talking about
[__] being a space cadet literally
that's what she's talking about is being
a space cadet
and this is why they can't elect a
speaker yes this is exactly why they
can't elect a speaker I'm going to
explain it let's let's do it let's
listen but we know that space force has
it all Trump has all the all the
information it's gonna okay what what
the space force okay back it up I
thought she said space force let's
listen the election I believe was stolen
MH but we know that space for has it all
Trump ah space force has it all there
you go well there you go you
know Men Are from Mars and women are
from Venus right a't that what it is or
is it women are from Mars Men Are from
Venus I don't know I don't
know what the space force has it all
does she know that the space force was
around when Trump was when Trump lost
why would the space force have it and
then not and then not say something hm
okay well let's keep going with the
crazy because it feels like this is
going to be hilarious if you want to
know the honest truth it actually is
Trump has all the all the yeah
information it's G to be overturned what
do you think space force
has I the question oh my god listen I
you think I I I'm I'm here to believe
that
rsbn like you think it's some kind a
right-wing Network like Trader TV's
network but really honestly at this
point I'm like are they literally just
like you know how much [__] content
can we make of these boneheads saying
this crazy ridiculous [__] into a
microphone are are they in on it with us
I'm start I'm starting to think that
like truly why why would they be asking
this person these
questions it does not help their cause
to ask this [__] ridiculous lunatic
in Michigan who stand there talking
about space
force okay all right space cadet tell us
what space force has space force is a
military branch of the you know just
like the Army you know all the military
and they literally walk up here they
literally she has to direct the
interviewer oh my God what the [__] is
going on keep going keep going with the
crazy lady this is going to be great the
night of the
yeah they literally literally watch the
election be stolen okay so they
literally okay you follow what she's
saying so I know it's difficult it's
[__] weird as [__] that the space
force who is in charge
of space I guess I don't know watch the
election be stolen on this planet or
another planet I'm confused I get it I
know that we're supposed to be able to
file this stuff
but [__] me running are you kidding me
okay well keep going keep going Karen
they know they Watermark the ballots
they know exactly what happened with
every ballot they know what fake ballots
all right doesn't oh okay wait okay all
right bear with me
here bear with me if you can see the
resemblance fake ballots they
watermarked them they knew f space force
knew they knew they knew they knew
things they knew great things great
things space force space force is like
the military of the of the of the
[__] space you know I'm talking like
Star Wars and Star Trek type stuff you
know what I'm saying it's fantastic I
did space force space force is the best
they knew they knew who was stealing the
election get the [__] out of here this
sounds like Trump this sounds like Trump
oh that's because it is
Trump this is Trump Okay so I was going
to talk about the house Speaker which
I'm going to get to why this is the
reason why they're having trouble in the
house let me tell you
something this is why Trump says the
[__] he says this is why he says it okay
is because these [__] ninka poop
Nazis are standing in line to come
listen to him say the [__] they already
say like literally he's goingon to go on
stage and he's gonna say this dumb [__]
that this lady is trying to regurgitate
already that she heard on o or Newsmax
or she heard on his true social page or
some dumb [__] okay it's all a big
[__] brainless circle jerk is all it
is and that's the reason why they cannot
select a house Speaker do you want to
know why they can't select a house
speaker because the people who are going
to vote for them believe that space
force is the most excellent thing ever
and but they W literally literally they
watched the election stolen by a bunch
of Jewish space lasers and the
watermarks and listen they actually flew
space force flew the ballots to Mars
they sorted out the ballots in Mars they
put the watermarks on them they flew
them back overnight and then they
stopped counting the votes so that way
Trump couldn't get elected president of
the I don't know what the [__] she's
trying to say you [__] make sense of
it they all they knew the election
switches they know what countes were
involved what countries yeah like the
United States the money politician
that's been paid off yeah they know
there's um buzz
6,000,000 get buzzwords buzzword sealed
indictments Buzz be up to 500,000 sealed
indictments boom boom buzzword I believe
that we're going to have an emergency
broadcast Buzz is going to come in the
law buzzword buzzword buzzword we are
going to be shown eight hours on give
him another give him another buzz word
hurry hurry hurry the world buzz word
Buzz
taped tribunal yeah buzzword buzzword
woohoo buzzword buzzword the world is
what's really going on Boom buzzword
buzzword buzzword one after the other
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam you get a buzzword
you get a buzz word you get a buzzword
you get a buzzword this is the dumbest
[__] I've ever seen in my [__] life
[Laughter]
and you [__] think that Trump
isn't GNA be the nominee you
[__] think that they were gonna
pick some reasonable person as the
Speaker of the
House you think these people are gonna
be reasonable get the [__] out of here
with that [__] are you kidding me listen
to this [__] lady let me rewind it I
don't to rewind it that far listen to
her listen to her this is she's voting
for the people who are picking the
speaker listen stolen yeah they know
they Watermark the ballots they know
exactly what happened with every report
SE crime Jordan for speaker Wooh they
knew the election switch countes were
involved yeah fake electors fake
electors stop politician that's been
paid off yeah know there's um there was
260,000
260 oh my God and you're [__]
wondering why Jim Jordan is going to be
Speaker of the House really you're
standing around wondering
that it's [__] ridiculous that I even
have to point this out to people are you
kidding me come on man she listen listen
folks I'm GNA tell you right now a fact
a fact I'm gonna tell it to you right
now are you ready this lady votes for
Republicans who have to go vote for a
republican Speaker of the
House are you following
me okay let me let me speak to the brain
de maglites out there this is how
Republic
works this is how it
works we elect people who go to
represent us us us the
people when you get [__] idiots like
this voting for people to go represent
her interest her interest is Watermark
ballot and the space force
all right space cadet all right that's
cool great fantastic and you think you
think the Republicans are in a situation
where this lady is one of their
constituents and they're representing
her and they're going to pick a
reasonable person for Speaker of the
House how in the [__] do you even begin
to believe that [__] and how the [__] do
you begin to believe that anything we
say or anything we do is going to make
it to where they're not going to be just
absolutely [__]
[__] what are you supposed to tell
this
lady I mean the woman with the
microphone standing there and only
encouraged her to say the crazy [__] in
front of the microphone here I'll back
it up I'll show you at the very
beginning
watch here okay watch watch she says
something about space force watch space
force has it all Trump has all the all
the yeah information
it's going to be overturned yep what do
you think space force has like literally
she's like oh this lady's [__] crazy
let's just pump some more crazy into our
audience I just pump some more crazy
into
it and the media doesn't get it either
like the media has no clue like they're
[__] blind to this literally there's
there's people who have been following
Congress covering Congress for [__]
decades on the hill this morning trying
to figure F out why there's 20 people
against Jim Jordan but the rest of the
caucus is for Jim
Jordan trying to figure that I have no
idea how why can't they pick a speaker
of the
house exhibit [__] Q okay this is
exhibit q and this is exhibit Q
1,562 okay this is the first exhibit q
that I'm going to give
you they can't elect a [__]
reasonable speaker because they're not
reasonable people do you got it they're
not representing reasonable people these
people are not reasonable anymore
they're just
not and that's the reason why
Republicans in the house can't select
someone who will bring people together
who will make sure to fix the government
blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah because they're plating to Qin
oners they are speaking qinon just like
when Donald Trump says calls a Biden B
calls Biden Obama he is not out of his
mind he is speaking to this
dumbass he is talking to her that's who
he's talking to okay and he's making her
think all kinds of crazy ass [__] so
that she'll still go vote for crazy and
that chaos will ensue and that Jim
Jordan will become the speaker of the
house so that way Donald Trump can
control Jim Jordan it's not complicated
to understand this [__] it really isn't
this isn't even politics this is just
[__] playground playground Theory
folks remember when you're on the
playground when you're a kid and oh well
I'm going to be in this group of kids
well I want to be in this group and that
group and oh well this person over here
runs this group and that person's in
charge of this group it's not [__]
difficult understand this [__] you do it
in your office every day too office
politics same [__] thing same [__]
[__] you don't have to go very far to
know this stuff it's not
difficult they're insane they're
insane but you know go ahead pick Jim
Jordan here's Mike Turner defending Jim
Jordan watch this Face the Nation watch
this [__] here's here's one of the
people who are elected by this [__]
bone B and boneheads like her listen to
this guy Jordan's working right now to
put that Coalition together to get to
217 so do the allegations that he turned
a blind eye to sexual assault at Ohio
University caus Brenan Brenan Brenan
Brenan the proper way to say it okay I
you're getting there you're so [__]
close oh you're so [__] close Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan that's
what that's how you that's how you do it
now you're getting closer you notice the
media is really
you notice the media has really come to
my position you notice that weird weird
it's almost like they're a year behind
me on this but you know what are you
gonna do go ahead go ahead ask him the
question I'll back it up a little bit so
you can hear go ahead get to 2 so do the
allegations that he turned a blind eyed
report University cause any problems for
you or the allegations that he had
knowledge of Donald Trump's attempts on
January 6 and leading up to it to stop
the election certification knowledge you
see what I mean she's I mean she's doing
a better job right they're doing better
but they're not there yet they're not
there yet knowledge that he helped
orchestrate in the House of
Representatives the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup attempt that's how you would say it
that's how you be visceral I don't know
if they know that but okay go ahead
let's see what let's see what this
fascist Mike Turner has to
say Mar the allegations at Ohio State
there's not one person who's ever said
that they have knowledge of Jim Jordan
having any knowledge wrong wrong lies
[__] lies now again you would think
you would think that Maran Brennan would
stop him right there I mean I would I
would be like wrong no stop stop stop
you know me when I want to say something
ah stop stop stop stop no stop stop stop
it what the [__] do you mean there's not
one
person what the [__] do you mean there's
not one person and I would go on to
proceed to be like okay all right all
right that's a good point and I'm gonna
play the clip here in just a second I
say well what about this person what
about this person what about this oh
what about this person not one person
[__] out of here you lying sack of [__]
and what occurred at Ohio State wasn't
even under Jim Jordan he was not wrong
false not not true not true [__]
[__] that fake news fake F news fake
news fake news fake news fake news stop
stop stop Mike Mike if you're gonna come
on my show and lie why don't you come up
with a better lie than that than one
that we can obviously prove okay what
the [__] is he talking about Jim Jordan
was at Ohio State when this [__] was
happening Not only was he at Ohio State
when it was found out that Jim Jordan
was at Ohio State and he was responsible
for these student athletes and their
safety he called to beg them to beg them
the their story so that people wouldn't
find out Mike you piece of trash not the
the head coach this is not he had
responsibility for so those oh oh oh
you're right you're right Mike you're
right you're right only only only the
head coach is responsible for student
athletes you're right any other coach
any other teacher any other staff member
that is employed by Ohio State had no
responsibility none to protect those
students ah you're right you're Pro you
[__] piece piece of [__] and these
are the save the children crowd these
are people that we have to stand around
listening to talking about they're going
to [__] save the children save this
and save that blah blah blah blah blah
and children's and children's this and
children's that [__] out of here with
this nonsense and this guy doesn't even
know that the the entire staff at Ohio
State is responsible for the safety of
those [__] student athletes and the
safety of the staff around them [__] you
you piece of [__] Mike Turner you need
to resign immediately you piece of trash
immediately you lying [__] sack of
[__] in disgrace because you're oh
that's right you're a republican though
you aren't going to do that making
accusations are making you know just
presumptions of well he would have had
to have known but it there's no one mind
you this was years ago no one who has
come forward at all ever and ever said
that there was actual knowledge on Jim
Jones party of course he condemns what
what occurred there do you see why now I
say that like if she would have called
him Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
why it would have been much more
effective
why because she's not even willing to
push back on him when he's telling lies
to to her [__] audience like
literally he just sitting there just
lying his ass off lies lies lies lies
lies lies lies lies because he knows
she'll let him get away with that and
half the audience would be like you know
what maybe GMI don't report sex crimes
Jordan isn't GMI don't report sex crimes
Jordan but if she said that he's Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan ah man
it' been a totally different [__]
ball game wouldn't wouldn't
wouldn't it be a totally ball game for
Mike Turner here continue with your lies
you piece of [__] with respect to Donald
Trump I you know that that's a mess
that's going to continue going on on the
issue of January 6 and Americans are
going to be able to have that debate as
we go forward in this next election
cycle so no no pause on your point part
for Jim Jordan uh do you think oh no
pause on your point for Jim Jordan I
mean she started off all right you know
what I mean like she brought up they're
getting there right they're they're
they're on the they're on the fact that
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan did
what he did in Ohio right they're
they're there they just don't know how
to use it right margan Margaret Brennan
here doesn't know how to use facts and
and to look at a congress person
especially a a republican Congress
person and call them a liar to their
[__] face because that's what he is
he's a [__] liar she knows he's a
[__] liar that's why watch at the
very end here watch is her disgust she's
disgusted watch this watch no no pause
on your point part for Jim Jordan uh do
you think she's disgusted she's like oh
my God I can't even believe you [__]
sit here and say that and support him no
then do your job do your [__] job
Margaret do your [__] job look up at
him in the [__] thing and say hey
you're lying you just you just told this
lie this lie and this Li to my audience
and I want to know why you're lying for
Jim Jordan I want to know why you're
lying for Jim Jordan Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan why are you doing that
why are you coming on my show and lying
to my audience it's almost like you're
trying to hide the sex crimes that Jim
Jordan was trying to hide Mike Turner
it's almost like you're okay with the
sex crimes that happened at Ohio State
and you're willing to stand back and
hide them just like Jim ji don't report
sex Rhymes Jordan was willing to hire
hide them huh that's what she would say
that's what she would do if she was
really for the truth if she was really
really trying to [__] be effective as
a media person and an interviewer as a
matter of fact that's how you [__]
interview someone who's [__] lying to
you flat out flat out [__] lying to
you Mike Turner what a piece of
trash supporting Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan he is Mike I
don't report report people who don't
report sex crimes Jordan if you want to
know the [__] God's onest truth but
it's no not surpris that the media dare
El than their
Duty because they're trying they're
trying to have themselves as a
non-biased place for Republicans to come
and feel safe because apparently
Republicans don't even feel safe on Fox
News anymore apparently I don't know
that's what Peter Navaro says look at
this [__] this is at the Great Awakening
oh my God you talk about a room full of
squirrel turds these people are nuttier
and [__] aren't they goddamn have you
heard of this the Great Awakening this
is the um Eric Trump goes and speaks at
these things this is Mike Flynn's this
is Mike Flynn's little U fascist nazi
religious rallies that he has oh my God
man [__] crazy [__] they they quote
Hitler at these things yes they quote
Hitler at these things they got they got
the moms of Liberty at these [__]
things you know the the great moms of
Hitler the the [__] with cancer
rolles the Taliban the minivan Taliban
you know what I'm talking about but
here's Peter Navaro now when I first
watched this clip I was like yeah I'll
show it to you listen listen the first
part listen I want to talk about now Fox
News yeah talk about it Peter turn that
off yeah yeah Peter Navaro turn that
[__] off turn Fox News off [__] Fox News
Boo Boo Boo [__] Fox News yeah I'm all
on board you know what I could I might
be able to get behind this Great
Awakening you know want to know the
honest truth I you know what hell I
might I might be I might be a supporter
of Peter Nar now keep going Peter tell
us tell us why we should turn on Fox
News tell us what we should watch Tony
Michaels I guarantee he's gonna say Tony
Michaels Tony Michaels tells the truth
let's listen
yeah tell them listen Tony Michaels tell
him Pete tell him Pete tell him newsx oh
[__] bannon's War Room n
uh voice Jesus [__] America news
network and all the podcast oh my God in
the clay Clark Flynn Universe clay Clark
Flynn Universe okay well he lost
[Music]
me H so so I see what he's doing there
do you see what he's doing oh my God
what a piece of [__] swamp sludge
this guy is he's like don't watch Fox
News because they're not fasy
enough that's what he was really saying
you thought you were gonna be on the
side of Peter Naro there for just a just
a second just a second right just a
second oh man I really thought we were
going to have Peter andaro back to the
uh to the reasonable side of reality
didn't you just for a second second
there one second I thought but
then that some [__] turned
me godd
damn oh boy and you think you think
these are reasonable
people you think they're reasonable
people remember out Fox News was their
was their altar that they worshiped oh
my God it was their [__] altar that
they worshiped they worshiped their
alter oh my God Fox News That's the [__]
Tucker Carlson
the judge Sean Hannity oh my God they
tell me the truth it's fair and balanced
they tell me the truth now they're all
[__] Liars over there because they
won't capitulate to the dictator and
King they won't select the speaker they
won't try to overturn democracy but you
know what the left doesn't get this
either the left doesn't understand the
right either they really don't Deborah
says it right here Flynn is [__]
dangerous yes Flynn is [__] dangerous
sorry Deborah I had to edit a little bit
with a [__] in there you know me thank
you for your comment but even the left
doesn't get this [__] they really don't
they don't understand this even the
president of United States doesn't quite
understand uh the situation we're in
he's getting there I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell you right now I know that you
don't probably like when I say cross
things about Joe Biden but Joe Biden
does not fully understand what is
happening I don't think I don't think he
fully gets it yet he's getting there
he's been getting there for a while but
I'm going to show you a clip here and
this is from 60 Minutes Tennessee holler
posted this on Twitter and this is a
short clip of the president United
States describing MAA in this country
listen does the dysfunction that we've
seen in Congress increase the danger in
the world yes
look this is not your father's
Republican party third okay so he's on
to something here he says yes it's
dangerous and it's not your father's
Republican party he's pretty he's pretty
spot on with that all right now notice
though why why the left isn't getting
this correct and why the left is falling
short of where we need to fall by the
time we get to next year listen to this
LIF listen 30% of is made up of these
mag Republicans who are maybe democracy
is something I don't they don't look at
same way you and I look at democracy
it's much worse than that Mr President
it is much worse than that they don't
look differently at
democracy they don't want
democracy they feel as if democracy
doesn't serve them anymore so they don't
want
democracy they don't want it because
democracy democracy supports the work of
the people it supports the masses it
supports the actual majority in this
country is what democracy
supports and it
absolutely absolutely rebukes every
single one of their culture wars that
they want to have and the reason why
they want to have these culture wars
again because they lost the culture wars
they were
humiliated by losing these culture wars
that's why they want to stoke them again
it's why they don't believe in democracy
because democracy will make tried that
they tried democracy using democracy to
win the culture wars and they [__]
lost they got [__]
trounced by democracy in their culture
wars they want to get rid of democracy
they want autocracy politics is not what
they want anymore they aren't interested
in legislating they are not interested
in have a speaker of the house they're
not interested keeping government open
they are not interested in anything that
our Republic our democratic consti
Republic would do for the people because
they don't give a [__] about the people
anymore our
constitution our government our
democracy our Republic does not serve
their needs
anymore they want
autocracy that is the only way that they
can get what they want which is to
destroy certain populations in this
country destroy them ostracize them
maybe even exterminate them to some
degree this is what fascists
do so I I am glad that the president of
United States is getting closer to those
facts but he's not there yet and folks
it is our job as the pro- Democracy
coalition to drag Kicking and Screaming
any Democrat I don't give a [__] who
they are what office they hold drag them
kicking and streaming to the [__]
truth and the truth of the matter is
there's an Insurgency in this country
and and they want to destroy our
Republic they want to destroy our
democracy that's why they work so hard
to convince people that it isn't a
democracy you ever seen this [__] you
seen this [__] they're like oh it's not
a democracy it's a republic oh look at
you liard you think you live in a
democracy
H oh look at you you don't even know the
definition of republic you don't even
know that we're that we're a republic
you liard you've had those comments
right here's a simple
fact that the rightwing knows if they
convince their simps right that lady on
the on the line who believes the space
force knows everything and Trump did the
thing and the thing in the and the
ballots and the watermarks and the and
a right that lady if they can convince
her of something as dumb as our country
is in a democracy
when they take it away from her when
they take democracy when they snatch
democracy right away from her you know
what she's going to say well we never
had democracy in the first place it
wasn't democracy anyways so why should I
care if they take away democracy because
there's one thing that the people who
stand around talking about well we're
Republic we're not a
democracy a republic does not have to be
a democracy folks I don't know if you
know that I don't know if you looked it
up before most of the time republics are
democracies but a republic does not have
to be a democracy it doesn't have to
be that form of government a
republic doesn't even have to have a
constitution it can just have an
autocrat who decides that they're going
to pick and choose who's going to
represent people in certain parts of
their country that's
right they can have an autocrat who
appoints the representatives of the
people in their image guess what they
can do too they can get rid of those
Representatives that's represent those
people in the
Republic a republic does not have to be
a
democracy that is what makes ours
distinctly a democracy you stupid
[__] shitty mogit
what makes our country a
democracy is our Democratic
Constitution that extends rights to all
people in this country including the
right to vote including the right to
free speech including the right to carry
weapons
guns you know the two amendments you
love the best oh I I really like those
two amendments the first one gives me
the right to say whatever I want to say
and the second one gives me the right to
shoot whoever I want to shoot that's
what they believe that's what they think
they
are but hey [__] eater hey [__] eater go
look up Republic and understand that a
republic does not have to be a democracy
but here's the thing folks I'm gonna let
you in on this I'm gonna let you in on
something the maglites don't
know the fascists know that the fascists
know that a republic does not have to be
a democracy that's why they're trying to
convince people in this country that we
don't live in a republic that is a
democracy because that way when they
snatch away their rights when they
snatch away their [__]
freedoms they stand around going well
we're a republic anyways it really
wasn't a [__] democracy I mean what
do I what do I need free speech for I
mean I used to love Free Speech but I
don't need free speech what do I need
guns for what I I don't really need guns
anymore Trump told me I don't need guns
that's what he said he said he's gonna
protect all of us I don't need
guns
they're unaware of the history of how
fascism Works they don't get it they
don't see it and frankly it is a little
bit alarming that even Democrats out
there even people who are part are not
Democrats that are part of the
pro-democracy Coalition aren't willing
to say that truth out
loud loudly and
proudly and explain what's going on in
our goddamn country because it is not a
situation we part of the Republican
Party looks at democracy a different way
than us that is not the truth Mr
President I am sorry to speak against
Joe Biden here but that is not the
truth they do not look at democracy a
different way than that we do they do
not believe in democracy
period they want to destroy democracy
period because democracy does not does
not serve their right to oppress you
period get it right know it it's the
actual threat here that's the thing that
we are up against autocracy verse
democracy they don't want
democracy and even if the Republicans
who do want
democracy you know there might be some
out there that identify as Republicans
that might want de that might truly want
democracy well you're not on the side of
democracy you're still in a party that
wants to destroy
it you're in a party that wants
authoritarianism so have some [__]
guts stop being a goddamn
coward get with the truth and the truth
is is that the Republican party in this
far as our democracy is concerned is
dead de a
d
dead dead
dead they don't want democracy so if you
want democracy in your Republican lead
the Republican Party drop the R I don't
care if you [__] if you go to the
Democratic party if you run as an
independent or that stupid ass party
libertarian that isn't a thing anyways
that's right libertarianism is not an
ideology by the
way not believing in
anything is not an
ideology at least at least to govern
it's
not so get it
straight I told you
earlier that in
2006 the Israelis left Gaza City they
left they packed their [__] and they
left and they left it to the
Palestinians to decide what would happen
in Gaza City guess what they did they
elected Hamas they elected a bunch of
fascist
terrorists as their government and it
was the last election that they
had MAA is America's
Hamas you give manga control in this
country that'd be the last [__]
election you
have' be the last [__] that's
what fascists
do especially when they're overtly
telling you oh you don't believe me that
they're telling you oh okay well let's
let's go to the
evidence let's go to the evidence Tony's
got the evidence trust me I've got it
here it is right on bji
show Benji Johnson let's listen let's
listen to what they these two these two
chuckleheads are saying right here what
they're going to do if they win let's
see let's see what they say Mike I've
never called for lava to rain down from
the heavens but maybe upon Washington DC
would you be that sweet red hot lava for
us I've never been called sweet and you
call me sweet Ginger so I I think I then
then um okay I I just want to say I just
want to say and I'm not trying to pass
judgment here I'm really not I'm really
not Ben Ben joh Benny Johnson is [__]
he's he's a closet he's closet G he's
he's gay he's gay I you know maybe my
gar is off here I'm I'm serious and I'm
just asking anyone out there that has a
better one than I do because I'm I'm
gonna be honest I don't have the best
one ever right I can't I can't always
pick out who they are right that
especially these [__] that are
trying to oppress gay people trying to
like conversion therapy and go and
Target and attack the lgbtq community
and [__] this [__] scumbag Ben
Johnson watch this exchange there about
the about the lava and the ginger tell
please someone tell me if he's gay or
not you just tell me I'm I'm asking lava
for us I've never been called sweet and
you called me sweet Ginger so I think I
me then during when did he call him
sweet Ginger when was this what were
they doing when they when he called them
sweet Ginger and I'm not opposed to two
heterosexual guys you know having some
homosexual banter back and forth I'm not
against that that's that's funny
sometimes that's funny but why are these
[__] attacking the lgbtq community
and then I don't
know playing you
know hold each other sack on air I don't
know maybe I'm maybe I'm off my rocker
I'm just I'm just saying well let's
watch
my three-week reign of terror As Trump
acting attorney general before I get
chased out of town with my trump pardon
I will reain hell on Washington DC we've
talked about this Ben I have five lists
to go they're growing list number one
we're gonna fire we're gonna fire a lot
of people in the executive branch in the
Deep state that is Project 2025 okay
that's what that is you guys have
probably heard of project 2025 that's
what he's describing there that fascist
little [__] circle jerk Hitler thing
okay let's keep going number two we're
gonna indict we're gonna indict Joe
Biden and Hunter Bon and James Bon and
every other scumball SAS ball Bon except
for the 5-year-old granddaughter who
they refused to acknowledge H for five
years until the political pressure got
to Joe Biden okay so they're going to
they're going to indict every single
member of the Biden family besides the
5-year-old girl I mean you know why
would you indict I mean they really want
to they really want to indict The
Five-Year girl but they're trying to
make a political Point okay keep going
that's number two what's number three
here uh uh fasy number three we're gonna
Deport we're gonna Deport a lot of
people 10 million people in growing
anchor babies their parents their
grandparents we're gonna put kids in
cages it's going to be
glorious okay did you hear that did you
hear that part did you hear that part
anyone who has any Hispanic descent ever
in their family lineage there or any any
foreign descent in your lineage I don't
care where you're from other than white
European countries I'm sure he's not
going to deport white Europeans um
they're going to deport not only Deport
them they're G Port their entire
families and they're going to deport and
they're going to deport and they're
going to put children in cages that's
what he says they're going to put
children in cages is what he says did
you catch that part okay all right we're
on to you you [__] Hitler lover okay
keep going we're going to detain a lot
of people in the D see goog uh and Geto
and list number five I'm G to recommend
a lot of pars every January 6th
defendant uh is gonna get a Parton
especially my hero horn man uh he is
definitely at the top of the Parton list
okay he's talking about the Qin on
Shaman and of course um um gay Johnson I
mean Benny Johnson Benny Johnson laugh
oh children in
cages oh you're going to put people in
the
goog oh you're going to indict and
execute Biden because that's what he's
saying about gitmo and the goog you
understand that right they're talking
about executing people is what they're
talking about and they're laughing about
it they're laughing about it and and
when he's talking about horn man he
means a Qin on Shaman Jacob Chanley
listen to Benny's response to that
listen
we we actually went out and have some
upcoming content with Jacob Chanley we
did a podcast interview with him uh went
out went out into the desert we wanted
to learn about Shamanism so we went out
of the desert with him we'll be
releasing that video uh pretty soon
actually and I think you'll like it
quite a bit oh thanks thanks for the
lead up for the content drop there you
[__] Nazi woohoo thanks for the
[__]
plug what
what that's right these these two are
circlejerking each other for the Q and
on Shaman and putting children in cages
and executing people at gitmo and the DC
goog I didn't say this [__] I didn't say
it just presenting you the evidence just
here to show you what the [__] they want
to
do trying to tell you trying to [__]
screaming out loud trying to show the
White House hey hey they're not [__]
Grandpa's political party they're Nazis
they're [__]
Nazis yelling and screaming it for
[__]
years this clip is old too that's not a
recent
clip it's not recent that's months old
that's months old then you have then you
have more [__] this is a great this is a
great political cartoon this is perfect
this perfectly describes Maga this
perfectly describes Maga
Republicans the Republican party right
here see this Gabriel Hansen for mayor
there you go YouTube's probably gonna
[__] ban me because I put this up but
I don't give a [__] [__] them [__] them
if this offend you if this [__]
offend you then you're out of your
[__] mind you're you're offended by
the wrong goddamn things if that's the
truth this is this was put in the chag
chattan newa Times Free Press the artist
is
Bennett
hell out of here with this
nonsense Joe Biden shouldn't be saying
that this is not your your grandfather's
Republican party he should be saying
this is not your grandfather's
Republican party because they're
Nazis they're [__]
Nazis yeah I know I know it's it's
extreme
rhetoric it's
extreme but what do you want what do you
want for me they're Nazis you want to
see some more proof that they're Nazis
and they're actually the blood sucking
cabal this is real this is not AI I
promise you this is [__] real I
didn't make this up this is on Donald
Trump's [__] social media this clip
right here I'm going to show you that
they're actually the blood sucking cabal
listen to what he says here listen to
who he says and what he says about them
listen carefully but remember
Republicans eat their young they really
do they eat what what what back that up
say it again say it again Grandpa but
remember Republicans eat their young
they really do they eat their young
terrible statement but it's true but
remember Republicans eat their young
they really do they eat their young
terrible statement but it's true huh but
remember Republicans eat their young
they really do they eat their young
terrible statement but it's true so they
do they eat it on Rye or they eat it on
white or wheat bread what do they do is
this like subway where you got to pick
the bread I don't know what the
Republicans eat their young what I mean
I guess that old Bible thing and stuff
huh I don't know I hey don't don't
[__] come at me he said it listen but
remember Republicans eat their young
they really do they eat their young
terrible statement but it's true it's
true Republicans eat their young it's a
terrible statement I hate to say it but
they do we love to eat children we love
it oh we love we love children then L
sliced with mayo ketchup and tomatoes
ketchup is a must you must have ketchup
you must have ketchup it has to be in a
small little bottle so you're not being
poisoned but you got to put ketchup on
your child sandwich it's a thing it's a
thing they eat their young it's terrible
to say but we do we do eat our young
what oh my God that's [__] real I
swear to you that's real I wish it I I
really wish it was AI
I wish it was I wish it
was I what do you want for me again I
don't get to make this [__]
up I don't get to make it
up let's see I had some other stuff I
wanted to show you guys oh yeah I got to
show you this video you know we got a
lot of religious zealots out there on
[__] Twitter right now they're
everywhere oh my God the religious
people are everywhere and they're making
the situation the world even worse you
know what I mean it's [__] really bad
they can't stop having stupid ass
opinions but when you get religious
people and then they get opinions this
kind of [__] that you get watch this
[__] tell me if you think if you think
this is crazy or not God is setting you
free right now is there anything you
wanted to
renounce I want to renounce generational
curse my child is autistic and he's he's
he's not's he has no brains at all or
like we've tried
everything what did he just say that his
child is autistic but and his child has
no brains is that what he said it feels
like that's what he said it feels like
that's what he said I don't know I don't
know this is guy is a Republican and he
eats his child as a sandwich or not but
I don't know let's let's see what the
hell's going on here his child has
autism but doesn't have brains I don't
know most autistic people have brains I
mean all of all of them all they're
humans right I think they have brains
maybe he ate the brains is the problem
he's a Republican and he ate the brains
maybe that's the I don't know and um
I've gone through Deliverance before and
it's just so hard to break this curse
God is breaking this generational curse
right now oh he is he is so okay so get
this this guy does not think that his
child has a brain which is wild stuff um
just because he's autistic
so clearly this person does not
understand autism but then he's talking
about Deliverance yeah star gals here is
going Deliverance what the [__] Deliver
Us from Evil that type of [__] you know
religion's really wacky but now God God
is gonna fix the problem of the child
not having a brain here okay it's a
generational curse and it's GNA fix the
child not having a brain apparently
let's see what let's see how God fixes
it thank you Jesus yeah his power is
here oh it's right there right now it is
time now for your deliverance and your
family's
Deliverance I break every generational
curse off of you off of this whole
family you know what's hilarious about
this this [__] totally would
show up at a trump rally talking about
space
force water marking ballots and [__]
what he
100% sa [__] St [__]
eats his kid as a sandwich eats his
kid's brains as a sandwich and totally
shows up toally shows up at a trump line
and talks about how space force
Watermark ballots okay keep going and I
detach this family and you from what you
spoke I declare every Spirit attached
every Spirit of Witchcraft every Spirit
of mental illness I declare on
scen that the [__] do a
somersault
he did a somersault watch this [__]
watch this [__] this guy's got
somersaults in his repertoire watch this
SP of mental illness I declare on three
all must leave him in Jesus
name I I just want to know how long he
practiced this thing right are you
serious are you [__] kidding me did
he just do a
summer summer Sals for Jesus is a't that
what that's called or that's a
sumersault
right oh my God sumers salts for Jesus
okay let's keep going let's see how
great he is let's see if he finishes it
off as good as he's started
two three now he's having an
orgasm oh okay
three
hallelujah thank you Jesus a [__]
power is enough
hallelujah hallelujah thank God for that
piece of content are you kidding me son
of a [__] let's keep doing more of that
could we could we please keep doing more
of that that would be fantastic if we
could show people how [__] out of
their minds these religious people are
because it's not the it's not the
[__] the lady on stage acting like
she's doing an exorcism right and it's
not the guy playing an actor and he's
doing G Su salts for Jesus or whatever
or he's coming for I don't know what
he's doing looks like he's having an
orgasm for Jesus you know what I mean
the [__] in the crowd look at
these [__] look at them look
look look at all these son [__] look
here look there look at all these
[__] people in the crowd yeah they
believe that [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah that was a great somersault
for Jesus look at that oh yeah
somersaults for
Jesus come inside me Jesus come inside
me come inside me I don't know what do
you want from me I don't
know you know it's crazy you can get
people to believe that that [__] is real
you can get them to commit
atrocities oh my God you can get them to
commit just utter
atrocities in the name of Jesus if you
can convince them that garbage is
real you can convince them to vote for
[__] some dumbass felon some piece of
[__] criminal who's a goddamn snake oil
salesman trust me if you can convince
these people this
nonsense you for sure can convince them
that Donald Trump should be the leader
of the Free World
folks that's the [__]
truth and we're standing around we're
standing around trying to figure out why
these people believe this [__] why that
why this [__] lady why this [__]
lady believes that the space force
Watermark ballots or some dumb
[__] we're really standing around trying
to figure this stuff out come
on it ain't hard to figure out this
stuff is not hard to figure out and this
stuff is not hard to realize that these
people these religious
zealots you don't they don't believe
anything they don't believe
anything speak speaking of religious
zealots you know I went on a tie
raade the last part of the a block
rant and um about Hamas and Israel one
of the best piece of content and I'm
actually surprised here I don't know
what celebrity he's gonna be dating next
for
this or if this makes his thing grow but
Pete Davidson did a wonderful job and
you know Lauren Michaels may not be the
best at picking people to do comedy on
Saturday Night Live he may not be the
best he's been doing it for a long
time but Lauren Michaels has a way of
picking the exact right person in these
times the exact right person in these
times to say
something about atrocities right here's
Pete Davidson over the weekend on sat
Line This is the cold open on Sat line
let's
listen this week we saw the horrible
images and stories from Israel and Gaza
and I know what you're thinking who
better to comment on it than Pete
Davidson well uh in a lot of ways uh I
am a good person to talk about it
because when I was seven years old uh my
dad was killed in a terrorist attack so
I know something about what that's like
um I saw so many terrible pictures this
week of children suffering Israeli
children and Palestinian children and uh
it took me back to a really horrible
horrible place and um you know no one in
this world deserves to suffer like that
you know especially not kids you know um
after my dad died my mom tried uh pretty
much everything she could do to cheer me
up I remember one day when I was eight
uh she got me what she thought was a
Disney movie uh but it was actually the
Eddie Murphy standup special
Delirious uh and we played it in the car
on the way home and when she heard the
things Eddie Murphy was saying uh she
tried to take it away um but then she
noticed something uh for the first time
in a long time I I was laughing again um
I don't understand it I really don't and
I never will but sometimes comedy is
really the only way forward tragedy um
you know my heart is with everyone whose
lives have been destroyed uh this week
um but tonight I'm gonna do what I've
always done in the face of tragedy and
that's try to be
funny um remember I said
try and live from New York it's Saturday
night there you go there's the cold open
for standing live where Pete Davidson
described how he lost his dad in 911 um
heartbreak um that any family who loses
someone in a tragedy especially a
terrorist attack um this week Pete
Davidson did a great job there uh
describing it and putting it in terms
that most Americans
should should understand um some of us
don't I don't know how we lost our way
here but some of us don't understand
that and some of us don't understand
that you know
what sometimes you just
can't you just can't but help use comedy
to work your way through a
tragedy you can't laugh at something or
you know set as set aside set aside
reality for just a second to laugh at
the facts to laugh at the
truth I try to do that here every
day sometimes I succeed sometimes I may
not I try to get you to see something
for what it is you know how hilarious it
is that the Republican party is fighting
over rather Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan should be the speaker of
the house do you have any idea how
hilarious that is that is absolutely
that is that is supposed to be something
that you make up and you can't even
really make that [__] up to be quite
honest and they're standing around
fighting over
that right now as we speak I bet I could
pull up four or five Clips right now
these some [__] fighting over it I
don't know you know let's go see if we
can find some
clips fighting over it right
now rather Jim Jordan should be the
speaker of the
house it's
hilarious I mean the reality of
it seems like a tragedy right because it
it really is that we're in a place in
our country where the only person that
is willing to come forward to be the
Speaker of the House wouldn't even come
forward when his students were being
sexually molested are you kidding
me this is the only person that we have
coming
forward
what as the atrocities happen in Israel
and Gaza the former president of United
States who claimed that he was
pro-israel is is is not is pro-
Hezbollah it's talking about how Hamas
and Hezbollah are
SM
really but I and I know it's
difficult I get that it's
difficult but these the things that are
true and we got to find some comedy in
them
somewhere but what we got to do rather
we laugh at it we scold at it we yell at
it we get our righteous anger up what we
have to continue to do is make sure
without a doubt that we tell the [__]
truth and while we're talking about Jim
I don't report sex crimes Jordan
becoming the speaker of the house
because again I could show you all kinds
of
Clips all kinds of clips of people
arguing back and forth whether he should
be the speaker of the house or
not I'm going to show you a
clip of something that Mike Turner
earlier said doesn't exist you can't
show me one you can't show me one person
not one
[__] that can verify that Jim
Jordan looked the other way as people
were sexually assaulted at his
university well I'm here to tell you
that [__]
exist it does exist it has existed for a
long
time this clip that I'm about to show
you did not happen
yesterday it didn't happen last week it
didn't happen when they considered Jim
Jordan Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan to be the speaker of the
house this has been around for a long
time if I can find something [__] I'm
looking give me a second I'm getting
there trying to find [__] here
it
is here it is Mike turn
you ready to see it you ready to see the
video of the person making claims
against Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan let's hear it Jim Jordan called
me
crying
graving on the 4th of
July begging me to go against my
brother begging
me crying for a half hour that's the
kind of coverups going that's going on
there Jim Jordan called me several times
after
that that week I had to have my lawyer
call him tell him to stop calling
me I had a teammate George paros I
called and told him call Jim Jordan and
tell him to quit calling me or I'm gonna
beat his he's throwing us under the bus
all of
us he's a
coward he's a coward he's not a leader
he's a
coward I'm a leader I I I was Captain to
these guys that's why I'm here I would
never abandon my
team he abandoned us our head coach
abandoned us he's flipped this story he
called other people to flip their story
he called Mark Coleman to flip his story
he called his parents 90 years old
that's the kind of person Jim Jordan is
there you go there's Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan the next speaker of
the
house that's who they want you know that
right that's who they
want that's who they want to be the
speaker of the
house that's what they want to have
happen got it are you on to do you
see very important distinction between
who they who who has to be and who they
want sons of [__] sons of [__]
let's see um oh we're getting um we're
getting news here from the uh I guess
Trump is going to do a speech today in
Iowa oh well let's let's go to Iowa
let's go to the big crowd there in Iowa
let's see all the people waiting for
their mango musini Jesus to show up in
Iowa all right all right George show us
the audience
[Music]
there some [__] that really
sucks sucks to suck don't it oh man tens
of people tens of people showed
up
oh [__] oh man MAA is gonna be really
super pissed when I say this and if skip
Cuts this and puts it in a short you
want to know the big lie do you want to
know the big lie from Donald Trump it
ain't that he [__] lost but he won
that ain't the big lie that ain't the
big lie the big lie is that a mass group
of people support this [__]
idiot they don't
they do not give a [__] about him look
at this he the former president United
State's most popular person on the
maanga planet is going to show up in
Iowa today and this is the crowd
awaiting him there it
is I don't know if you caught that but
half the half the half the [__]
people there are dummies literal dummies
look 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 going on
and on literal dummies there's more
dummies there than there are Trump
supporters folks look at
that literal [__]
dummies come on man and I'm supposed to
be
convinced they literally they literally
are now at Trump rallies putting [__]
dummies and hoodies and t-shirts Trump
hoodies and t-shirts and [__] TR to
convince people that there's actual
people there are you seeing that watch
watch there's more dummies there than
people
[Music]
waiting godd damn that's sad that's sad
[__] is
it tens of dummies show up to support
Donald Trump today in
Iowa dummies George you say yeah I said
dummies what oh that's sus sucks to suck
wait wait wait do we have no that's not
something I thought I thought we had
more from the Gabriel Hansen campaign
well let's see let's go
um I was trying to find a goddamn clip
of these bastards fighting in the house
that they're going to make Jim Jordan
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan the
leader of the House the speaker I'm
trying to find a damn video of it but
you know I can't find it
um let's
see and I'm trying to find there's
another video out there of the president
United States uh showing
up at a rally um and boy he had a really
big crowd there much bigger than the one
of the crowd of dummies that you just
saw that is in support of Donald Trump
um but I'm not finding it and we're
about to close anyways you know what I
mean the show is winding to an end today
I appreciate you guys joining us here on
YouTube on Twitch on Facebook I don't
want to forget Facebook did you know if
you're on Facebook and I really really
don't know what this is now but you can
give Stars over there in support that's
right you can give us stars on Facebook
so make sure if you're on Facebook you
consider giving the show
Stars I guess they're like worth money
or something on on on Twitch it's called
cheering I believe on YouTube it would
normally be called super chat but I
don't I YouTube doesn't give me the
ability to Super Chat anymore it
probably won't be long before Facebook
and and twitch cut me off to be quite
honest oh oh here we go here we go I got
the I got the I got the clip you're
looking for maybe here it is here's Jim
I don't report sex crimes Jordan let's
go to it Ann Wagner and Mike Rogers uh
publicly saying they would support us
two great members uh who do all kinds of
great work um so that was uh that was
that was really really big so I feel I
feel real good about the momentum we
have and oh yeah I feel good about uh
Mike Turner going on CNN your station
and lying for me lying for me about all
the all the sex Grimes that I just look
the other way hear no evil see no evil
speak no evil Jim Jordan come on now
literally he is being interviewed by the
[__] organization that Mike Turner
who he's describing is supporting him
and his speakership went on their
[__] their Sunday show in L to let's
see if they give him any push back let's
see I'm hoping I'm really hoping I think
we're we're real close so the vot's
gonna be tomorrow do you do you uh will
you go to the floor even if you don't
have 27 tomorrow that's that's how our
system our great system works um and we
will go to floor tomorrow um it's not
about pressuring anybody just about we
got to have a speaker you can open the
house and do the work of the American
people and help our dearest and closest
friend Israel if you don't have a
speaker so we get speaker we we get the
house open and we get to work on the
resolution and and supplemental for for
Israel um and we get back to work for
the American people and that's what
I'm h no so no push back I guess no push
back no I guess
not not a single push back from that not
a single push back about Mike Turner
going on CNN and lying about the
allegations of Jim Jordan lying that not
one person when I just showed you not
one person has said that allegation
let's see if there's any at all
committed to doing I think it's gonna
happen tomorrow because you had said
before you want to have 217 first well I
do think that's that's ideal but as one
of my colleagues in the room I don't
know if there's any way to ever get that
in the room I would love that but I
think the only way to do this is the way
the founders intended is you uh you have
the vote tomorrow um we've set it for
12:00
and um I feel real good about it you
have more than one ballot they they they
won't have the vote tomorrow by the way
but let's keep going you don't get to
217 on the first we're gonna like to
speaker tomorrow that's that's that's
what I think's gonna
happen Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan lying to himself again that's
what he that's what he think is gonna
happen you know what I mean that's what
he thinks is going to
happen is that he is going to he is
going to be a Ed speaker
tomorrow just like he believes that
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden committed
some kind of
atrocity now let's see let's see this
morning if Kevin McCarthy decides he's
going to step in on the floor vote
tomorrow Congressman uh Mr Speaker
thanks so much appreciate it not Mr
Speaker remember I will never give up I
care too much about thiser done a
helpful out of fundraisers and
recruiting to get the majority thanks uh
thanks so much Kevin appreciate it thank
you thanks Kevin circle jerk circle jerk
can we please circle jerk can we get a
circle jerk over here hey can we get a
circle jerk over here it's it's a fox
and friends we need a circle jerk for
Kevin McCarthy who's a [__] loser
that's right he's the ex speaker and he
the loser the party of losers manga is
holy [__] let's see if we can get
another clip of these [__]
chuckleheads talking about how they're
going to get how they're going to get to
217 here's here's Steve wol ma of
Arkansas let's see if he thinks Jim Jim
I don't report SE rmes Jordan is going
to be a great
pick we'll know when when I vote uh how
I vote and I will make my intentions
known with all of the people that are
important in this I just want to point
out this guy's from Arkansas I just want
to point out number one he's not
standing in front of a $19,000 Podium
which is kind of Dar licked in his duty
apparently if you're a politician from
Arkansas you have to carry around a
$19,000 Podium where wherever you go but
I also want to point out that this guy
should not be in Congress because he's
not wearing a suit he's wearing what
appears to be some kind of windbreaker
fleece hoodie type thing or it's not got
a hood on it but it's like a fleece
windbreaker thing why the [__] is he
allowed to walk around the halls of the
capital with this thing on I thought I
thought I really thought that it was it
was it was IR IR
reprehensible for any member of the the
senate or congress to walk around in a
sweatshirt what in the [__] is going on
here all right keep going let's hear
your nonsense decisionmaking process to
include Mr Jordan uh but I know there
are concerns from the Appropriations
Committee after all two weeks ago Mr
Jordan voted against the continuing
resolution on the very day that the the
funding was about to lapse and so he in
essence voted for a government shutdown
and I and I know that concerns a lot of
appropriators we're concerned about the
numbers uh that we are being told to
write our bills to I'm a I'm a chairman
of a subcommittee we're we're concerned
about those Topline numbers that we're
being forced to write to that we know
and most everybody did you notice that a
lot of Republicans are just now
realizing that they're in the Republican
party are you noticing that like they're
standing around like oh yes Jim Jordan
Jim Jordan's the one who voted to to
shut down the government oh just him
just him oh okay what the [__] out of
here they're just now realizing like in
this moment they're like oh godamn I've
been a member of the Republican party
this whole time well son of a
[__] come on man you can't be serious
right you can't be serious he knows are
not going to become law because they're
going to have to be balanced out with
what the recommendations are in the
Senate you got to get to 60 votes you
can have a your appropriation said all
along that given the divisions in the
body politic right now and let's face it
the country is divided no it's not you
[__] [__] there's no Democrats
standing around not deciding who the
[__] their speaker would be every one of
the Democrats every [__] time every
time every single [__] time every
last one of them voted for Hakeem Jeff
every [__] time they're not divided
they are not divided it's not a thing
you're making it up because it makes you
feel all good inside inside your [__]
sweatshirt you [__] idiot so the
Congress is
divided congress not divided republicans
in Congress are divided difficult for
either party to be able to impose its
will on the other and no see what
happens is what happens is is um we have
majorities and minorities because we
have a two-party system okay so that's
what happens in our Congress whether
it's in the Congress in the House of
Representatives or it's in the Senate
see you [__] idiot here's what
happens when the majority has the
majority they elect their leaders okay
now rather it's in the Senate you dumb
son of a [__] or it's in the House of
Representatives they elect their leaders
that's how it works you we elect you you
go elect the leaders and then you run
the [__] government see you govern
you govern oh we're appropriators we're
not we're not legislators we're
appropriators we appropriate weo
appropriate you don't appropriate you're
part of the the Republican party they
don't appropriate any funds you ready to
work with
Democrats uh I work with Democrats every
day I
mean this [__] he's like no no
really we're we got we got offices in
the same building we're in the same
building I mean I work here they work
here we kind of you know they work over
there I work over here we work together
I mean we're here we're both here in the
same damn building you know what I mean
you know what I mean I mean to get a
governing major oh he talks to them uh
if it comes to that the it'll be a
conference decision the conference will
have to decide at some point in time how
urgent it is for us to get this
government functioning again and with
what's going on in Israel I think we're
getting closer and closer to that point
but if it becomes apparent that nobody
and I've said this uh publicly nobody in
America can get 217 right now out of the
Republican conference if that becomes
apparent to everybody then at some point
in time we're going to have to work
across the aisle try to figure out what
it's going to take for us to be able to
get a speaker elected and then get the
the ball rolling in Congress once again
oh there you have
it they can't govern that's what he's
saying we can't govern because we're
Republicans we'll know we're
Republicans we can't govern we can't
govern we're Republicans because one
reason one reason only one reason and
one reason only I'll show it to you
right here the [__] crybaby and chief
Grandpa poopy pants the Cheeto dust q
and honor Donald Trump will not let them
govern because governing means that
there is no chaos and without chaos this
[__] crybaby little [__] doesn't
exist just like the Republicans in the
house the MAA Republicans the clown car
is empty and there's no clowns left to
be the speaker
that's why you watch this show every
single weekday Monday through Friday
because I'll stay on top of these idiots
subscribe here on YouTube and don't
forget to hit the Subscribe button and
the thumbs up and if you don't like when
I say hell hit the thumbs down goodbye
me just don't forget to engage in your
democracy and engage with the Tony
Michaels podcast same time same place
tomorrow surf up you
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking but remember Republicans eat
their young they really do they eat
their young terrible statement but it's
true but remember Republicans eat their
young they really do they eat their
young terrible statement but it's true
but remember Republicans eat their young
they really do they eat their young
terrible statement but it's
true